hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gehts raps und zwar werde ich so
ja so mediterrane raps machen mit
hähnchen gefüllt und mit gegrilltem
gemüse also ich werde das gemüse jetzt
nicht auf den grill sondern in der
pfanne grill aber ihr könnt das zum
beispiel auch im krieg grillen und da
kommt später noch eine joghurt dressing
mit drauf und die sind dann wirklich
super mediterran und sehr lecker
ich brauche dafür eine gelbe paprika
eine rote paprika eine aubergine hier
noch ein römer salat etwas olivenöl
ich habe ich zwei hinten brust filets
und ein paar gewürze und zwar in halben
teelöffel salz und halben teelöffel
paprikapulver halben teelöffel oregano
und etwas pfeffer und hier habe ich noch
ein bisschen wasser ich werde zuerst
einmal das gemüse klein schneiden und
zwar ist es bei paprika so wenn ihr dazu
erst unten diesen herr deckel sage ich
man den boden weg schneidet könnt ihr
alle vier seiten zur unterscheiden
man kann man nämlich super gut schneiden
ich schneide jetzt in feine streifen die
sind so etwa einen zentimeter breit
ein bisschen weniger
eben schon mal einen esslöffel olivenöl
in einer heißen pfanne und kann jetzt
die paprika stücke mit dazugeben und die
frage drückt mir das jetzt etwa 2 3
minuten anbraten und in der zwischenzeit
kann ich schon mal die aubergine in
dünne scheiben schneiden
die auberginen werde tanzen und zwar
sorgt dafür dass sie später beim
anbraten mit soviel öl reinziehen
aber die müssen jetzt natürlich noch ein
bisschen ziehen also ruhig ordentlich
tanzen auf jede scheibe und damit das
ganze jetzt mit 100 offizieren sieht und
eine bespitzelt oder ihnen andere
schlüssel 170 die sitzreihen und die
flüssigkeit die dann rauskommt dann kann
man darunter tropfen
sobald sie hatte gestern ein bisschen
farbe angenommen haben und was sie
können gelände noch daran und werden
dann schönwald und ich kann schon mal in
der pfanne sich auch ein mitfahrer
nochmal teelöffel olivenöl einig und
darin dass fleisch anbraten
die zwei stücke wendig sein sobald die
eine seite gut gebräunt ist
die kleinen ins brauchen jetzt insgesamt
nur 13 minuten und das kurze film
braucht bestimmt 80 10 minuten
ich musste zumal die zwischenzeit und
wetten salat film schneiden und zwar
schneide ich den in dünne streifen zieht
man hier ganz deutlich dass die
auberginen flüssigkeit verloren haben
auch wenn man sich ausdrückt kommt er
ganz viel flüssigkeit heraus
die muss jetzt natürlich noch kurz kalt
abspülen weil er ganz viel salz dran ist
dann werde ich sie ausdrücken und dann
auch gleich anbraten
die auberginen verlieren so übrigens
nicht nur die feuchtigkeit und sorgen
weniger fett auf sondern sie verlieren
so auch die bitterstoffe
jetzt kommt noch etwas salz und pfeffer
auch die paprikaschoten dann haben die
nämlich schön auch einen eigenen
geschmack
jetzt nämlich direkt paprika pater
pfanne und kann in der gleichen planer
die auberginen scheiben anbraten
minute noch ein bisschen olivenöl
benötigt gibt es einfach mit dazu
die mache ich jetzt denke ich in zwei
drei fraktionen
die aubergine sein rausnehmen wenn sie
von beiden seiten gebräunt sind
ich werde jetzt mal kurz fertig backen
und dann kommt gleich ein video bekannt
sobald die auberginen fertig sind werden
die auch gesalzen ich gleich rum und
jetzt kann ich schon mal das fleisch
nehmen und das in streifen schneiden und
es muss ja dann auch gleich noch würzen
und hab das fleisch ist im ganzen
gebraten und nicht vorher in stücke
geschnitten weil es so einfach saftiger
bleibt
für das fleisch noch gewöhnt mit pfeffer
und mit den gewürzen die ich vorhin
vorgestellt habt also salz oregano und
etwas paprikapulver ich kann da jetzt
ganz einfach mit den händen bis zu
vermischen
jetzt bin ich fast fertig jetzt muss ich
noch das joghurt dressing machen das
passt findig geschmacklich richtig gut
mit dazu sprach 200 gramm joghurt hier
noch ein paar gewürze und zwar ein
viertel teelöffel saales in halben
teelöffel minze und ein halber teelöffel
oregano einen teelöffel 14 weißweinessig
und etwas pfeffer geht jetzt ganz
einfach denn wir verrühren einfach alles
miteinander
der essig sorgt hier so ein bisschen für
die säure
dies finde ich ganz wichtig und ich hab
dieses mal gar keine scherte mit dabei
als wärs ein bisschen scharf mag so wie
ich da kann natürlich noch chili mit
hinzufügen zum fleisch ich hab sie zweck
gelassen sollte murat sich manchmal
beschwerlich wirtschaft kommen auf jeden
fall ist hier die minze ganz wichtig die
getrocknete denn die macht das ganze
auch zum militär habe ich alle
komponenten vorbereitet hole kurz meine
weizen raps und wti über dem heißen
wasserdampf noch ein bisschen erhitzen
damit sie weich werden oder können wir
gleich befüllen gebe zuerst einmal das
fleisch drauf und es ist auch schön
klein geschnitten
dann die aubergine nicht so gerne
gesehen aber ich finde es gehört einfach
mit aktion paprikaschoten okay das snap
zuvor machen sonst kann ich den gleichen
zahlen und etwas joghurt vergessen der
junge jude ist mit dem intel das
schmeckt einfach super genial nicht mehr
so viel platz für salat
das ist kein problem diese neue beilage
sally jetzt hier beide seiten ein
klappen gibt es erstmal alles müsse
zurück und jetzt darfst du hast du mein
teller manchmal mich alles voll drauf ok
den reva danke wie gesagt ich würde
jetzt persönlich noch bis zum 1
also du merkst richtig den salat
also bevor jetzt wieder rein
stopfmaschine schmeckt gar nicht richtig
und das fleisch und die so sehr
elegantes ob sie nur string ich wusste
nie was drin jetzt durchgekriegt also
worauf ich auch verzichtet habe ist
knoblauch natürlich könnt ihr hier auch
gerne knoblauch mit einfügen
aber ich finde man sollte hier auf jeden
fall die minze herausschmecken und dann
einfach so hin bringt aber ich lege aber
nicht von dem riff was anderes das heute
einfach schlafen
woran wohl ja ja so falls sie auch
dieses rezept nach machen wollt dann
geht auf sell off - blog.de da gibt es
das rezept zu lesen mediterranen rap war
gut vorstellen können mit zurück dann
machte aber nicht dazu vielleicht mach
deinen eigenen rap ja mit so job ich
würde da keine nomaden käse ein machen
so zum toom penny toom penny oliven
maier würdigte machen also macht den
einfach oder ich mache ja marina krohne
weil ich in den 10 volt natürlich ja
bitte macht er ohne okay dann kann man
auch gerne einen monat machen
und jetzt wünsche ich mir schon mal ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen und nachkochen
und wir sehen uns das recht immer wieder
biss dann später wieder erstaunt darüber
wie schnell du etwas aufessen kann
verwerten